you know that the question will we ever
stop using animals in a harmful way in a
cruel way in a selfish way is maybe the
most important question we face this in
this time is not just our ideas about
animals it's our ideas about the water
the air the forest the soil the earth
itself we are connected to all of it and
there's an interconnected web of
existence and when one part of that web
is harmed the whole network is somehow
harmed and human beings are just
beginning to realize that in this time
whether or not they will stop abusing
each other and the other animals remains
to be seen I can't really say you know
human beings how do have the ability to
do surprising things to launch
revolutions to become to to create
golden ages where there's a a nurturing
of the whole world culture the
environment and and that's not with it
that's not outside of our reach
definitely we could do it whether we
want to or not that's the question
you